concerns about
climate change and the impact of so many
people on the planet now
has led anna hughes to a life-changing
decision
she lives close to nature on a houseboat
in north london
but says she'll never have children
there are lots of people
on the planet and and there's only a
certain amount of space and a certain
number of resources that we have here so
um that that kind of comes to a crunch
point at some point doesn't it you can't
just
continue to have ever more people it's
just there's only
it doesn't work so i am i became quite
aware of that and i thought
actually that's not something i want to
contribute to
the current global population is nearly
8 billion
new predictions suggest the number will
peak in 2064
at nearly 10 billion but the figure
would then decline to around
8.8 billion by 2100
of the fastest shrinking populations
will be in asia
and europe populations are expected to
more than
halve in spain italy and japan
and it's predicted there will be some
big population
booms the population of sub-saharan
africa
could triple by 2100 to over 3 billion
it's easy to associate the world's
growing population with the climate
emergency
but some argue stabilizing the
population
is not the solution a lot of people link
population to climate change the problem
here is
actually not everybody emits the same
amount
so the interesting thing is it's not the
number of people that
causes climate change it's what we do
and how much we consume
and of course how much we admit
within 50 years we may see the global
population start to decline
by then without drastic action the full
consequences of our climate emergency
will also be known lisa holland sky news